reflects on how you have to come and
deal with that mess so do you are you're
you're basically saying that the girl
with less body still has trauma is that
your point yes yeah yeah but we're
talking about like a balance of
probabilities so if a girl's been with
50 dudes versus five dudes who's who's
more likely going to have more trauma
yeah just to balance of probabilities
and you know I mean I've always said I
like Rolo tomasi has a quote where it's
like it's not the number it's the number
of like guys that she saw Alpha as Alpha
so it's like the number of men that
she's comparing you to but the bigger
the number is the more it's just a
balance of probabilities but when like
when you were talking earlier about
dating and sex like is sex is just a
physical act you can sleep with a guy
that you're not dating and that whether
that be a one-night stand or just a
fling like why does that necessarily
need to affect you in that way that it
puts you through trauma it doesn't you
can do that yeah like that's totally
fine but men don't want to deal with
that
again the characteristics of a woman
that frees it up to that capacity is
gonna have other implications in that
relationship and again why would you as
a man want to take that risk what kind
of implications are we talking about
here so if we're talking about like
promiscuity and the effect it can have
on a relationship
if that man isn't taking all the
biological boxes whereas he probably
would be would have been before if the
woman was less promiscuous the
likelihood is that she's more likely to
stay we caught the statistic before that
70 to 80 of women leave their men it's
not men leaving it's women leaving so if
men are out here having more sex and
women are having more sex but the
consequence of us both having more sex
you're less likely to stay with me then
what you're doing is causing a problem
to successful relationships so you're
actively breaking up nuclear homes
because you can't maintain your
discipline and women are leaving because
of sex then because of financial reasons
that we said so it's not about I don't I
mean did you know one of the number one
indicators of divorce is the woman out
earning the man I can see that yeah but
it goes back to because the woman one of
the reasons is because the woman is
around all these men that she wants but
then no but then if if we're talking
about is it is it sex or is it money
because if it's if she's if she's
leaving because he's not earned enough
that's different than this no that's
selfish but that's it's about being a
selfish woman that is selfish if you're
leaving and breaking up at home because
he's not earning enough money that's
selfish it's okay to want that but if
you if you sign the papers if you got
married to him and now you think you're
above him because you make more I
remember quite sure but we're talking
about characteristics here so yeah with
the characteristics of a woman that
wants to free up for everybody when she
is around me that she wants she's going
to act in those those feelings whereas a
woman who's more disciplined is able to
say no to things because she's had less
and they say that 20 of men are raising
a kid that's not theirs that's why they
don't want to promiscuous woman they're
afraid they're going to pass the
resources on to the wrong
um onto a kid that's not there well
unknowing or knowing not knowing so how
do they get the statistic I don't know
it's DNA tests
when they find out I just want to know
how that was how that was possible we
literally support to a lady yesterday
that said that the guy was the kid was
11 years old before you found out the
woman just came clean because
unconscious couldn't take it no more mad
this is what man have to go through do
you think they wow do you think the
woman
stay or do you think they settle because
it's like if they've been exposed to
airbnc men one toxic one really nice
they know how then to spot a really nice
guy and a toxic one whereas like if
they've had maybe one boyfriend and
that's the only toxic one they've had
that's the only familiarity they've had
with a partner do you know what I mean
so sometimes having say a promiscuous
girl they have that knowledge now you
see what you go ahead like men do
because you're saying now men can spread
their seeds so they know what they want
logically that makes sense yeah then we
have the data to prove that that doesn't
work so what you're saying would be make
sense in an ideal world but ideally that
doesn't actually happen I mean why do
you think why do you think fathers were
so involved in the vetting process for
women we don't make good decisions in
men on our own
no I don't know like that's why half of
women over 30 are single and childless
because the average age of first
marriage is 27 to 28 in the U.S and in
the UK it's 31. so clearly how involved
is your dad going to be in the vetting
process for a husband if you're 31.
saying that as well look at the the idea
when people say oh she has daddy issues
because without without a masculine
presence to guide you you're bound to
make bad mistakes father presence
remember masking something not all five
was a Mexican yeah a masculine father a
masculine presence that is able to tell
right from wrong when it comes to men
what about beer for about a beta father
and beta
no matter
I think having a formula Alpha back then
I think having a father figure for
example Mike my godfather like brought
me up
he wasn't what macho man he he provided
he basically doesn't mean much to Amanda
I know but but we said earlier that's
what kind of what people go to
Dependable we didn't say much or okay
masculine so masculine for me is a macho
I don't see it asleep
my mistake let me tell you what I think
of when I think of masculine just like a
woman's point of view it's a guy that
doesn't put up with women's [ __ ] so when
I think of a beta guy I think of a guy
that just bends over and does whatever
the girl wants and she's he's just will
do anything to make her happy but not in
a good way like he's a kiss ass and when
I think of a masculine man I think of a
guy that is not afraid to say no and put
his foot down and he enjoys being the
leader in a relationship
because we don't we don't like men that
we can walk all over correct yeah yeah
like like the the nice guys they're not
actually nice they're just trying to buy
your attention with with things instead
of just being a masculine man
yeah I don't know because like my my
godfather for example uh he like he
would lead base my grandmother would
choose what he's gonna wear when they go
out to some men that's like no what are
you doing but he's like whatever is it
different dinos doesn't take anything
for me to put on the clothes she chose
out for me in the wardrobe but I
realized that now at my series was
always a beating man or he's not a
masculine man but he definitely run he
ran the household but so does she it's
like maybe I've seen different Dynamics
happening men and women have different
roles and households I mean I mean some
masculine men they're not afraid to dish
out responsibilities to women that
they're good at like my my parents ran a
business together and my mom is very
organized my dad isn't she does a lot of
the organization type stuff right and
like the finances but at the end of the
day he's dishing out the
responsibilities she's not he's the one
he's the one saying what's happening if
there's a big move he's the one making
the decision she's not and that's part
of we talk about submission at times for
her opinion
in making those decisions before making
the oh yeah I mean of course but but she
had to earn that he didn't he he didn't
just off the bat give her the ask for
her opinion all the time how did she
earn it loyalty and showing that she's
competent and giving him peace I imagine
as well yeah I mean because my mom
um
my mom and dad went to different
colleges and basically my mom told or my
dad told my mom you can either move to
me or find a different boyfriend and she
moved to him quit and then she ended up
getting a teaching degree she quit her
teaching job to work for my dad and
helped him build a multi-million dollar
business they had 10 kids but you know
in modern day they would say you know
don't take that risk for a man it's only
going to end up don't quit your job for
a man it's only gonna end poorly it's
funny my dad would say a similar thing
my dad would say to my mom well he said
and tell us is that I would see the
bigger picture while she sees her to
find the details so everybody has the
role to play Within the system it's the
cultures as well behind it like there's
a lot of I am was with like a lot of um
Filipino people from like the older
generation and in their like culture at
least back in their day was get for the
women as well get an education first if
you was to get married before in
education the family would discern you
because it's like one snap of a divorce
and you've got nothing and you've left
us in the Filipino culture really that's
interesting it was so much about it I
don't know about like all around that
continent of Asia but at least there
they said to me
education always comes first and then
when you have that education backed up
then you would go pursue maybe a
relationship or whatever because if you
left especially with a woman changing
your last name there's nothing there
holding you as much towards them so it
really does depend on the culture with
oh the presence with people I don't know
if you want to get a statistic but no
yeah no the reason what I was looking up
is um I when I want to see how
westernized the country is I look at the
average age of first marriage in a
country so one country I didn't realize
was so westernized as Ireland
um the average age of first marriage
there is like 34 and 35. because the
more traditional it is they they get
married younger typically is what I what
I've seen this is just anecdotal but the
in the Philippines is 27 and 29 so I
guess they're westernized too are they
now yeah well at least the people I
speak were much older so I don't know if
it was just because older times like you
said your parents would have said
something different because maybe in
their times it was different but I know
now
it's probably more westernized a lot of
cultures now though isn't it like even
like the Eastern South Florida and yeah
it's messing [ __ ] up
um I think with the point that he was
making with the example you gave about
your mum and dad and their working
relationship yeah I think that works
well because your dad did not
um that's what Ox did he ask for her
opinion before making I think a lot of
men take this
um this tattoo of leadership and run
with it to the point where you almost
forget that you have a woman that who's
who's almost meant to to help you
essentially what are the examples of
that
a lot of time the men that that take the
title of leadership and uh use it to the
point where in any in everything in
everything they they think okay I'm the
leader I'm gonna make all the decisions
without asking for your opinion without
but essentially that's your part that's
a dictatorship yeah yeah yeah yeah
essentially that's it but that's that's
what I'm trying to say so it's a thing
where if you are going to to demand that
to ask for
um or the title of being of being a
leader you have to know what it actually
entails and I feel like a lot of a lot
of people don't know how to do that so
with a lot of these things a lot of a
lot of what we are discussing it's all
well and good but with if it's not
taught to the younger generation they're
growing up they're going to grow up with
with misconceptions about the realities
of life well I think most masculine men
that I talk to are okay with asking for
a woman's opinion like because on on
YouTube I meet a lot of guys make it
like stupid amounts of money like more
money than I'll ever make but I know
more about YouTube than them and I've
had a lot of them ask me for advice on
YouTube I think they just know like they
understand the men and women have
different roles
I'm also want to say also you have to
remember as well that just being born a
man doesn't give you the entitlement of
leadership yeah she said yeah
you have to show the qualities of of
what a leader has before you can have
the title leadership so like you and a
lot of men who watch Kevin Samuels I
think oh yeah whatever he says is right
and I'm you need to submit to me look
these things have to be earned unless
you prove yourself as worthy of these
things you're not entitled to them so
let's make that clear you know what's
funny so I I said I I like to run a lot
of my decisions through man so uh my
like I talked to my dad I get a lot of
advice for for things on my channel and
just like business decisions I also have
a manager that's a guy and I run a lot
of my decisions through him and so um I
I always say that I like to run
decisions through men because they are
they're bad are at making decisions when
they think more long term and I just
think that's an
um an advantage that men have right not
all men but there's one guy who sent me
an email that just was like the subject
was a man to make your decisions and he
was basically propositioning like making
my decisions for me because he was a guy
do you think though I was like the
audacity
he's a fool and I was like which one of
you did that
like I didn't need any man I'm not like
a competent one yeah yeah do you think
they're like a man just is seen more as
a leader role whereas like if a woman
wanted to be like head of anything it
seemed more as a challenge crafty like
it is in a certain way like a man could
go for a spot and it's
more respected upon whereas like say
like a woman is ahead of anything it's
very like foreign still to us which is
kind of sad no you know what I mean I
think it's an advantage oh my gosh yeah
every time I've worked in Corporate
America they're trying to move me up
because they they have quotas they're
specific quotas where they need a
certain amount of women working I've
always worked in like male-dominated
Industries I think that's one of the
reasons my channel took off yeah is
because I'm one of the few women that
talks about this stuff like I think
being a woman is an advantage in
business I've never felt disadvantage in
any way in the world a few years ago I
can't remember what year it was but then
I think they changed the tax system and
then a bunch of companies made women
CEOs
um literally just obviously when
positions became open you just see it
out because these were now still working
in finance I was on LinkedIn every day
this new CEO's owned that new CEOs and
that new CEOs woman so that she said
it's actually very advantageous in this
day and age it's Advantage to be a woman
seeking out leadership roles or seeking
those Niche especially highly
specialized skilled roles because they
did they want you in Tech they want you
in engineering they want to make the
company look good his branding is a lot
of different things but they want you
there so now is the best opportunity for
women to get into these high paid roles
um I'll be honest I used to get in a lot
of trouble with my mom because I used to
say that
um I think men again